he says he feels like he's come home and
he certainly looks it full honors for
the American president broad smiles and
warm Irish greetings from his
counterpart Michael D Higgins
Joe Biden has been welcomed back to
Ireland like a prodigal son looks just
like the White House right
for the fiercely proud irish-american
president this visit is personal as well
as political as the Irish saying goes
your feet will bring you where your
heart is
as U.S presidents Kennedy Reagan Clinton
and Obama have all before him Joe Biden
planted a tree
and rang the peace Bell for Ireland for
America fourth one for peace and the
president's Irish ancestors
ancestors will hear even more about no
doubts before this trip is done for all
his family ties and his genuine love of
this place Joe Biden also knows that
this is just good politics he's a
president who says he's now planning on
running for re-election and all this
will play well back home
the president celebrated peace on this
trip but it's calm at a time of war in
the Irish Parliament the leader of the
Free World repeated his call to stand
firm over Ukraine
including thought the world would look
the other way
was confident he would break nato in the
European Union
the unity of Western nations would
fracture and fall at the moment of
testing that's what he thought
but he was wrong
meeting the president earlier the Irish
T shook Leo varadka applauded his
leadership in this time of conflict if
it wasn't for American leadership and if
it wasn't for America and Europe working
together
I don't know what kind of world we live
in so we we really do appreciate your
your leadership
[Music]
apart from this slightly alarming near
miss the visit has gone to plan and
landed well on both sides of the Irish
Border
he's been late for almost every meeting
but otherwise through a packed schedule
of Pomp and ceremony the president has
largely stuck to script and avoided
controversy my grandpa Finnegan
used to say if you're lucky enough to be
Irish you're lucky enough
if he announces His official re-election
bid soon the warm welcome he's had here
can only help him with the launch of
that campaign Dominic wagorn Sky News
Dublin